à un moment donné de la vie de chacun, vous
devez décider si vous allez vous en tenir
à la façon dont vous avez été élevé ou
écouter votre propre boussole interne dans le
monde divergent une fois que vous quittez le nid,
il n'y a pas de retour en arrière
après tant d'années de guerre et  douleur que l'
humanité a atteint à un moment où la
seule façon qu'ils se percevaient d'avoir
survit pour créer un nouveau système de
démocratie et qui se divise
en cinq façons différentes de penser
cinq factions ces paradigmes de
pensée la compassion l'honnêteté l'
altruisme et la bravoure représentent la
société ces  cinq familles de factions différentes que
vous devez choisir pour appartenir à l'
une d'entre elles chaque plan de faction a un
rôle à jouer pour faire tourner les rouages
et faire fonctionner le monde, mais il y a
beaucoup de contrôle qui s'exerce sur les gens qui
doivent servir leur faction la diversion suit
une jeune femme Triss qui a quitté sa famille
pour choisir une faction différente
ne perdons pas ne représentons pas en quelque sorte la
sécurité le côté militaire de la chose
s'ils étaient presque comme une force armée mais
trismus divergents, ce qui signifie qu'elle ne peut pas
être classée dans une seule
mode individuelle dans ce monde, cela pourrait vous coûter
la vie
divergente est un voyage fantastique, c'est
si précisément fidèle au livre que
Monica a écrit ce film  il vous emmène dans des
montagnes russes d'émotions à travers les
expériences des personnages c'est vraiment un film sur le
choix et comment vous
vous définissez qu'une décision qu'un jour
vous décidez façonnera votre vie
pour toujours
je pense que la raison pour laquelle tant de gens s'y sont
connectés est  parce que c'est
quelque chose auquel vous pouvez vous identifier, il s'agit
beaucoup d'appartenir à quelque part et de
faire ce choix et de prendre cet
engagement, il y a beaucoup de choses à
dire à ce sujet